[Música]
bienvenidos enlacentino desde Ecuador en
esta emisión hablaremos de la
despenalización del aborto en Ecuador en
caso de violación desde su vigencia en
abril 2021 repasaremos Cuáles fueron las
demandas y que concentraron a
movimientos pro y contra el aborto ante
el parlamento ecuatoriano además
hablaremos con una madre que en su hija
de 13 años Fue violada con otra mujer
que recurrió en aborto médico y con
profesionales que apoyan y rechazan la
nueva ley
[Música]
18 meses han transcurrido desde que la
corte constitucional emitiera la
sentencia que despenalice el aborto por
violación en Ecuador a consecuencias de
esta ley aprobada por el parlamento
ecuatoriano ya se comienzan a ver
fuertes protestas de grupos a favor en
contra del aborto caracterizaron las
concentraciones en torno a la asamblea
nacional durante enero y febrero de 2021
luego de una sentencia de la corte
constitucional que desviralizó el aborto
en Casos de violación exclusiva para
mujeres con discapacidad mental o riesgo
de vida Los parlamentarios debatieron
durante dos meses el texto legal el
número de semanas para la interrupción
del embarazo fue el tema que tensó las
discusiones que variaba para mujeres
niñas o integrantes de la ruralidad el
presidente de la república vetó
parcialmente el texto legal que
restringe los requisitos de acceso al
aborto entre ellos reducir pasos a 12
semanas para mujeres y niñas exigir la
presentación de una denuncia la
declaración de un examen médico o
declaración juramentada el 50% de las
solicitantes de aborto existen de
continuar el proceso por miedo a
realizar una denuncia o por los
obstáculos en el sistema Público de
salud
a 100 días de aprobada la ley solo ocho
víctimas a violación accedieron al
aborto legal entre el 29 de abril de
2021 al 6 de agosto 2022 según datos de
la Organización de acompañamiento
asesoría legal Sur cuna que promueve el
acceso informado al aborto María fue una
de ellas
esta madre de una niña de 13 años de
edad que sufrió violación reclama que
fue rechazada y discriminada a los
hospitales y fiscalía la falta de ayuda
puso a su hija en desventaja con un
embarazo de 15 semanas excediendo las 12
permitidas por la ley para acceder a un
aborto legal es mentira porque no nos
ayuda yo pasé con mi hija Por cuántas
fiscalías no solo por una y nunca me
supieron dar la ayuda que yo necesitaba
Yo quisiera que todo eso cambie porque
habemos habemos madres que estamos
apoyando a nuestras hijas pero hay
muchas mujeres que a las niñas les votan
a un lado desamparadas y ellas son niñas
en el año 2021 hubo
41.245 nacidos vivos de madres con
edades entre los 10 y 19 años de edad
113 niñas y adolescentes su madres cada
día en Ecuador según el Instituto
Nacional de estadística esta cifra
inquietan a Vera activista del colectivo
feminista sus cuna que ofrece apoyo
legal para acceder a un aborto seguro y
está en contra de que el nuevo texto
legal obliga a la maternidad no deseada
desamparar la mujer y no garantiza
derechos la ley como está planteada
realmente es una ley bastante
restrictiva
que impide a las mujeres y a las niñas
Acceder al proceso más o menos si
quieres haciendo como un comparativo
nosotras con sentencia acompañamos 22
casos más o menos de mujeres niñas sobre
todo que necesitaban acceder a un aborto
por violación y después de que se
expedido la ley el Ministerio ha
reportado que solamente se han hecho
ocho abortos por causar violación no Y
eso se debe a las múltiples barreras de
acceso que incorpora esta ley 50% de la
sobrevivientes de violación se ven
expuestas a las clandestinidad por los
obstáculos relacionados con los
requisitos de acceso a este derecho y
desisten de continuar el proceso legal
quienes sí cuentan con los recursos
económicos aseguran que el aborto es un
privilegio de clases sociales en Ecuador
esta joven a quien le protegemos su
identidad visita el especialista por un
aborto médico
750 abortos controlados Se realizaron en
Ecuador en el año 2021 según datos del
Instituto Nacional de estadística me
siento en una posición de privilegio
Porque primero he recibido educación
tengo las posibilidades para poder
hacerlo con un doctor de confianza
porque realmente el estado no no ampara
la mujer en este en este caso ni en
ninguno a pesar que los médicos se le
permite gigante la interrupción del
embarazo el estigma social está presente
en todos los casos y prefieren ocultarse
algunos prestadores que estamos de
acuerdo en que el aborto Debería ser
legal
y regulado eso científicamente ya sea
comprobado que no aumenta los la tasa de
abortos pero sí disminuye la tasa de
daños en las mujeres a causa de un
aborto o un procedimiento más realizado
sin embargo hay quienes han cambiado de
opinión con la nueva ley la exactivista
proaborto Amparo Medina hoy persuada a
las mujeres ha desistido la interrupción
del embarazo para ella la ley no
Resuelve la desigualdad social de muchas
mujeres envueltas en la pobreza que les
motiva el aborto les ofrece servicios
médicos alimentación y capacitación
laboral para que tenga luz a sus hijos
es grave porque se pierde el sentido del
respeto a la vida entonces hoy tenemos
la posibilidad de decidir Quién mata y
quién no mata Y esto se ve repercutido
también en todo hay una repercusión en
toda la violencia social que estamos
viviendo
457 menores de 14 años dieron a luz en
Ecuador en el año 2021 según la Fuente
oficial
activistas de mandar una ley ante la
Corte constitucional y aspiran que sea
declarada inconstitucional además que el
estado y los prestadores de servicio
reconozca la causa de salud para
garantizar el aborto por un embarazo no
deseado porque aseguran no cumple con
Los estándares Internacionales de los
Derechos Humanos hasta aquí esta emisión
de enlace andino desde Ecuador les
invito a seguir con la programación de
France 24 en español Gracias por
acompañarnos hasta la próxima